la contreoffensive ukrainienne s'est
soldée par un échec
pourquoi et si le rapport de force avait
changé et si l'Ukraine perdait la
guerre lancé en juin dernier dans l'Est
et le Sud du pays la contreoffensive de
Kiev était censé percer les lignes de
défense russe l'objectif rejoindre la
mer d'Azof et rompre le pont
ravitaillement entre la Russie et la
péninsule de Crimée annexée par Moscou
en 2014 6 mois plus tard l'armée est
encore à quelques centaines de
kilomètres de la mer d'Azof et les
Russes tiennent toujours la plupart de
leurs positions le front bouge très très
peu parce que c'est très difficile
d'attaquer donc on regardz ligne de
front Laou voilà il y a bmut qui a été
prise par les Russes en janvier ils ont
relancé une offensive qui a à peine
progressé puis là ça ça bouge en réalité
de quelques kilomètres carrés de part et
d'autre parce que la défense des deux
côtés est beaucoup plus forte que les
moyens d'attaque on a sous-estimé une
nouvelle fois la résilience de l'armée
russe on a cru qu'elle allait s'effondré
sous le poids des des morts qui qui qui
atteignent des sommes astronomiques ce
n'a pas du tout été le cas la Russie a
fait repartir ses industries d'armement
réussi à avoir des n dé munitions sur le
terrain alors qu'a-t-il manqué à l'armée
ukrainienne il faut beaucoup de
puissance de feu pour neutraliser la
défense c'estd il faut beaucoup
d'artillerie au bout de munition
aériennees de frappe pour voilà vous
arrivez à écraser toute cette défense la
neutraliser en terme militaire vous
empêcher de de de manœuvrer d'agir vous
empêcher les gens de les ennemis au
moins de combattre alors ce manque
d'équipement militaire et la conséquence
d'une aide internationale qui a été
importante mais qui reste aujourd'hui
insuffisante les Occidentaux ont aidé
l'Ukraine mais ils n'ont pas aidé
suffisamment l'Ukraine et ils l'ont aidé
trop lentement c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont
envoyé des armes vraiment au comptegte
de peur que les Ukrainiens ne les
utilisent contre la Russie et de peur de
réactions intempestives de la Russie
sachant que
Moscou menace d'utiliser les armes
tactiques nucléaires depuis le début de
la guerre et puis il y a aussi un
problème de stock de munition notre
industrie n'est pas encore
relancée pour suffisamment pour là aussi
produire en quantité un peu plus un peu
plus importante ça viendra mais ça ça
prend ça prendra du temps et puis vous
rajoutez là-dessus he peut-être parfois
des problèmes purement administratifs ou
politiqu qui font que entre le moment où
vous promettez quelque chose et le
moment où ces équipements arrivent sur
le terrain bah il peut se passer
beaucoup de temps dimanche 19 novembre
l'Ukraine a affirmé avoir repoussé
l'armée russe de 3 à 8 km de profondeur
sur la rive gauche du nièpre occupée par
l'armée de Moscou il s'agit de la plus
grosse poussée de l'armée ukrainienne
face au russe depuis plusieurs mois mais
sur le reste du territoire ukrainien les
positions sont en revanche figées les
front risque de ne pas bouger pendant
l'hiver à moins d'un à moins d'un
miracle alors ça pourra bouger peut-être
le jour où les Ukrainiens recevront les
bombardiers F16 de fabrication
américaine qui doivent leur être livrés
alors ça ça peut être un un Game changer
alors l'Ukraine peut-elle encore gagner
la guerre elle peut la gagner elle peut
la perdre aussi la seule chose qui soit
certaine c'est que on voit pas une
victoire claire de la Russie à long
terme c'està-dire que même si la Russie
arrive à à conserver les territoires
qu'elle a aujourd'hui elle sortira de
cette aventure militaire tellement
affaiblie qu'il aura forcément des
conséquences un jour politique à Moscou
le conflit entre Israël et le Hamas a
aussi un impact important dans la guerre
en
Raine juste après l'attaque du Hamas en
octobre dernier l'Ukraine a disparu des
médias et des réunions
aujourd'hui les Ukrainiens disent qu'ils
sont déjà engagés dans une compétition
en fait entre l'Ukraine et Israël pour
la fourniture des munitions les
Ukrainiens ont peur en fait de faire les
frais de cette nouvelle guerre qui en
revanche fait les affaires de Vladimir
Poutine